yesterday beanstalk farms a stable coin
protocol based on ethereum network
actually had 182 million dollars stolen
now this follows a 600 million a hack in
the d5 ecosystem just a couple of days
ago this is becoming more popular it's
important to understand exactly how the
attackers are actually carrying out
these exploitations what we saw was that
182 million dollars was stolen through a
very very unique attack vector the
nefarious actors showed up they took a
flash loan meaning that they could
borrow a ton of money without actually
putting up any collateral using that
flash loan they then were able to
establish the fact that they had a ton
of the governance token that is native
to the beanstalk protocol once they had
that governance token they put forward
an improvement proposal and they were
actually able to push it forward because
of how much of a say they had in the
network once they pushed for that
improvement proposal they were able to
withdraw 182 million dollars into their
own private ethereum wallet address now
as almost salt on the womb they took 250
000 and they donated it to the ukraine
crypto donation forum but that doesn't
necessarily mean that they donated it
all they donated about 250k but that
doesn't mean they donated at all it's
still about 182 million dollars so
pretty crazy to watch that now of course
if we take a look the beanstalk project
leads what did they say well of course
they forgot to have a flash loan
resistant measure that would determine
the percent of stock that had been voted
in favor of the vip this was the fault
that allowed the hacker to exploit the
protocol as we continue to watch the
defy ecosystem and various other
protocols get built out we have to
remember this is all experimentation
nobody knows where the innovation is
going to come from nobody actually
understands how a lot of this stuff
works we have to remain vigilant we have
to remember that there's large amounts
of money at stake but the risk is off
the charts part of the critique of the
defy ecosystem and many of the smart
contract platforms by the bitcoin
community is that ultimately there is
too much flippant attitude towards how
much risk is actually being taken not
only by the protocol developers but also
by the users if you are going to have
hundreds of millions of dollars or
billions of dollars at stake
you better damn be sure that you have
high security and that you are resistant
to these types of attacks ultimately
what we're watching play out here is
simply a market being developed the
nefarious actors are going to continue
to exploit these types of issues until
it becomes standard practice and
well-accepted structure on how to
prevent them nobody wants to see 182
million dollars stolen but ultimately
this is a lesson learned for every
single protocol developer every single
d5 application make sure that people
can't just go get a flash loan take over
your governance process and then
withdraw the funds to their own wallet
that sounded insane until we literally
watched it happen yesterday hopefully
the entire ecosystem and industry will
be better off for this having happened
because we'll learn a valuable lesson
maybe the funds will get recovered maybe
they won't but 182 million dollars is
better than if someone had went and
stolen billions and billions once we got
later down the road hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time